[Music]
let's go to erin in
sioux falls south dakota or souks falls
as they say nobody says that actually
what's up aaron how are you man
hey i'm good dr d how are you
outstanding so what's up brother how can
i help man
well okay so here's my thing i've been
working from home for about 18 months
now what do you do for a living what do
you do for a living
i'm a software engineer
excellent okay so you've been
engineering from the house you have a
cool setup are you like on top of a
washing machine or something
um i actually i started in uh a cleared
off desk in my uh bedroom and then uh
finally moved me into an office well a
room very
very cool very cool all right man so
you're working from home 18 months
software engineer got your own fancy
home office what's up
um
i i like it a lot but um just the last
couple months especially i feel like i'm
starting to fall into this trap where
i'm treating my wife more like a
co-worker or business partner and less
like my spouse and lover
and
it
i don't know i
i feel like
i used to have these nice clear
delineations of
i go to work i'm at work i come home i'm
come home and now i don't really have
any boundaries because it all happens
under the same roof all the time yeah
so give me an example of the way things
used to be and what caused you what
happened that you call caused you to
call to realize dude i got a problem
uh
like used to be like
when i went out and had a commute or
um
i mean
i think one of the things
really recently that was kind of a blow
up between my wife and me
was you know sometimes
when i had an office like i'd you know
need to schedule something with a
with a financial advisor or something
and just be oh okay well you know swing
by we'll grab a break room or be
somebody in-house and you know we'll
grab a break room for 15 minutes and
have a chat
and
i did that recently
and
it was on me i'm stupid um
but i i
scheduled a quick meet with a financial
advisor at the house and forgot to tell
my wife
uh i got you
um this was not good
[Applause]
it sounds like an honest simple mistake
and you're beating yourself up over it
is this the 15th time this has happened
and she's asked you to not do that or is
she sick of you like that seems rather
benign tell me how it's not
um
i mean this specifically was the first
time this had happened but
i i think it's more
just
i don't know sometimes i
like
i don't know if this may even make sense
like
i mean we've been married for 19 years
yeah um
yeah you got little ones
we do
some of them aren't so little anymore
but yeah we've got
we've got five kids
oh
yeah and uh and and she's great she's
been a stay-at-home mom since the first
one was born 16 almost 16 years ago
okay um and we homeschool
oh my gosh
and you know so she's
fantastic at that and sometimes feels
like just running the house as a
business unto itself yeah
um
but i don't know it it
feels like it was easier
when i went off to work to come home and
be like
there's my lovely wife there there's my
lover
and now it's kind of like i see you
every day
all the time and i'm not sure if you're
my wife or my co-worker
who's kind of getting on my nerves and i
can't get away from anymore and i know
i'm sure i'm doing the same thing i know
i'm doing the same thing to her i'm a
guy
so i annoy her and i don't even think
about it i don't even realize it
so
number one thank you for calling
for real
um
i know this is not an easy call and i'm
gonna stereotype you but a
it's probably an even more complex call
for a software engineer who's used to
being in their head and
architecting things it's not even a word
but
um
and having to navigate these family
relationships all day every day is just
new okay and i want you to rest in that
millions and millions of people are
dealing with this right now
everybody you know was cool to work from
home and to do these meetings for my
bedroom and to wear sweats during
whatever and we're starting to see folks
desperate to give back to the office
just for
the routine the separation the different
types of relationships all those things
you're talking about experiencing
um and not everybody's gonna be able to
go back or something's gonna be part
time back and so all i have to say is
you're in a situation that a bajillion
other people are in and i applaud you
for having the courage to call okay
so
there is a ton going on at your house is
that right
yeah that's five homeschooled kids is 5x
laundry plus 5x learning things plus 5x
people on the internet plus 5x dishes
all that stuff right
yep and
when you leave and go to work you are
right your wife's the ceo of the house
she's running stuff
right and you're not there to help and
so she knows her roles are clearly
defined as you have agreed on him and
your roles are clearly defined and when
everybody's here it gets all mushed up
right
and
so there's two things i think are
important here number one
there is a direct inverse correlation
between
safety and desire safety and romance
familiarity and desire okay
and what happens when you go to work and
you come home even if it's a tiny bit
there's some mystery there
that's that there she is
and that's when you walk on the door and
she looks at you and goes there he is
right there's a little bit of mystery
there what's been going on who's been
checking him out what's she been doing
there's that
it adds some spice if you will
and then when you are in the same
routine he's gonna be wearing this and
talking about that and the same coffee
cup in the same spot in the same sink
man there is no room for mystery and
there's no room for desire and so it
sounds bananas and
and by the way put five kids on top of
this trying to parent during a pandemic
five
um kids plus you worried about your job
and the market and and and and then on
top of that put um
it's hard to
find room for romance with five kids and
20 years of marriage anyway right all
that stuff's there
have you guys stepped away and just said
where are we done a state of the union
of aaron and your wife's marriage have
you all done that
yeah we really haven't okay
you deserve that and she deserves that
how old are your kids
[Applause]
almost 16
14
12
10 and just about eight okay
i think they are old enough
if if i mean obviously you guys do what
you need to do but they're old enough
that uh y'all can get away for a weekend
and it's not a hey we're gonna get away
and we're just gonna try to rekindle old
romance and i'm going to put on some
candles and a song that i like and see
if we can make out that might happen
hopefully it does but it's bigger than
that
this is a
state of the union how are we doing i
miss you
all of a sudden this work from home that
started was just going to be 30 days to
flatten the curve turned into four
months turned into nine months now it's
18 months later
and there's something about just hitting
pause turning all the lights on and
being like hey what's up i miss you
let's be open with one another
and it gives both of you an opportunity
to talk and it starts with i miss you
and i know that i'm not being the guy
that i want to be
i know that
if i'm
i'm so impressed with the work you're
doing around here and running the ship
but you and i are becoming co-workers
and i want to get the romance back and i
want to get the desire back and that
leads me to number two you guys have to
practice desire and so one of the things
you've i don't know if you listen to the
show very often but i always talk about
the analogy that i just beat to death
over and over is
the twin towers
twin towers got hit by those planes and
they fell down
we couldn't sweep up all that glass and
all that metal and all that steel and
recreate those towers they were gone
what had to happen is everything had to
be excavated call in an architect call
an engineering firm who had to rebuild
something new something that's actually
stronger some would say it's more
beautiful
and there's a monument to what was but
we're going to build something new
that's what you all guys get to do now
because what was is different what was
is going it used to be dad went to work
he doesn't do that anymore now he's here
and it would give her an opportunity to
speak into i really would love this
right i really would love that here's a
simple solution for
if you need to have meetings at the
house
and it's you saying i'm so stupid you're
going no it wasn't that it's that i
mentioned this three times and you
didn't hear me those does that make
sense so what you're doing is you're
saying hey we're gonna excavate
everything that was up until now we had
this type of marriage everything's
different because i work from here now
so what is it going to look like what
cool thing can we build moving forward
and how are we going to practice desire
in
inside this thing what is our sex life
going to look like what is our fantasy
life together going to look like what is
dating each other gonna look like what
is
um going out what is me helping around
the house now that you see me
um what is that gonna look like does
that make sense what i'm saying aaron
yeah yeah that that makes a lot of sense
and my hope is that you all approach
this with excitement and vigor of for
what could be
not a mourning of what's lost
you might mourn what was
it used to be cool to have an hour to
yourself to drive and to listen to
whatever podcast you want maybe now that
turns into a morning walk and once
you're done with work you take a walk
around the block for 30 more minutes a
you're going to feel better b you're
going to get some sunshine and see
you've got some markers in your day that
i was working now i'm dead
and same with her she's gonna take a
walk in the morning to gear up for
teaching half dozen kids and then she's
gonna take go to the gym or whatever
that looks like for your family does
that make sense but you're gonna build
some of these things in and it can be
exciting and it can be fun it could be a
new a new canvas you all are painting
it's only when you try to recreate what
was
that you try to drag the past in the
future that it just wears everybody out
because you can't get it back does that
make sense
yeah
it's really remarkable that you called
this out on yourself that's awesome that
puts you so far ahead of other guys i
know
it's amazing
usually it's a wife calling me saying
hammoth into my rope or a husband
calling and saying we don't have sex
anymore it's my wife's fault and you
peel it all the way back and you realize
oh you have five kids you've been
working from home for 18 months and here
does that make sense so you've been able
to look in the mirror and be like i'm
contributing to this i know
i don't know what to do next right so my
recommendation here's my prescription
you all get away for a weekend and dig
into it okay and part of it is gonna be
where are we part of it's gonna be
lamenting what was and then the exciting
part is let's build something awesome
and then we're going to practice it
moving forward how's that sound
yeah that i like that i think
i think that's something we can
definitely do and
then and move forward with something
cool i love that and if it's really rad
if you all come back with some um here's
who we are right um here's who we're
going to be here's what our marriage is
going to look like it's going to look
different and then you invite the kids
in on it
they'll all roll their eyes like gross
no i don't talk about this
bring him in on it here's who we're
going to be moving forward this is how
this is going to work
um we're going to make this work because
this looks like this is the rest of our
life it's not but it feels like it is
and then in 18 months you're going to
get called back to the office you know
guys are going to go on another retreat
and do this whole thing over again
we had this rhythm and now the rhythm's
different now we're playing a different
song as a family and so what's that
going to look like
um you're a stud aaron i appreciate you
a lot and i want to know how that
retreat goes so after you go on this
retreat send kell an email let us know
how it goes and if i can help with
anything moving forward let me know
appreciate you man